damn our ideas we're not that good
booyah
never say that ever again
hi you guys i am olivia holt and i play
kate wallace
hi i'm kiara aurelia and i play jeanette
turner hey i'm elise barnes and i play
vincent fuller hey my name is for
gutierrez and i play
jamie henson hi my name is harley quinn
smith and i play mallory higgins on
cruel summer and we are here with
buzzfeed today to read
your fan tweets and theories
annabelle was martin's girlfriend and
she
killed herself not his dad so when he
saw kate
in distress he saved her
because he couldn't do that for
annabelle and then
he put her in the basement to protect
her and made her pretend to be annabelle
it's not a bad one i've heard crazier
ones
that's why i definitely
it's very detailed yeah they should be a
writer
i know i honestly think so many of these
people should be writers the ideas that
they're coming up with
are incredible literally seriously
our ideas we're not that good like this
is not that complicated
[Laughter]
also shout out to at olivia holt
and at kiara aurelia for doing an
amazing job of portraying their
characters throughout the years and
showing the subtle differences in
mannerisms and such
hey girl thank you so much
i said where's the lie you guys are
killing it
where's the lie this ominous tweet says
i would let harley quinn smith destroy
my life
yes i mean
and
[Music]
okay so no one is credited with playing
the role of annabelle
in cast listings for hashtag cruel
summer that means she's played by either
an existing cast member
or a delusion we never actually see
alternate personality of kate
for starters they're really smart by
going and looking at castles
okay that's good okay
okay use imdb for your own
it's time now guys annabelle come out
the actress playing mallory is doing a
great job
dot dot i dislike her character so much
first of all oh my god that's not nice
you're not allowed to dislike maori no
okay thank you yeah i've gotten so many
comments saying that mallory's so
sketchy be it
as it may i don't
she's dressed up like needle juice in
episode four
but also mallory's 95 things are
fully the best thing i've ever
i want them in real life i think we can
arrange that i'll buy you some clip-on
bangs on amazon don't you worry girl
vince and ben holding hands and dancing
at a queer party they're so cute
this emoji
wow thank you everyone's so nice to me
i'm i don't know i feel so special
vince is like the only extremely likable
character
oh god this is my favorite character in
the show
by far he's like so kind vince is a name
the rest of us are sketchy
what if kate developed a split
personality
when she was held captive and when she
saw jamie kissing jeanette it was
annabelle her second personality that
told the police about
jeanette i don't even understand that
wait
that sounds like a different show
but that sounds like a good show
split number three question mark
i need a round of applause for the
costume designer for this show
especially kate's outfits
i want them all yeah
olivia looked hot as hell
as always olivia could not
not look hot don't you because that
looks good in an
80s style leotard there is nothing like
congratulations
and all caps okay so i feel like kate
sold jeanette's necklace the night she
saw jamie and her kissing exclamation
point three times
maybe she broke into her house or
something i just need to know if the
timestamp
is correct like did kate give the
evidence before or after she saw them
kissing okay i gotta say
i gotta say it is sketchy that she
reports it after she sees us kissing in
the park that's all i'm saying
and i'm sure there's multiple necklaces
too
you know like not my necklace guys
they're just kiosk necklaces at the mall
i don't know any custom necklaces that
cost seven dollars
i'm pretty sure there are plenty she
runs to the mall
she buys a necklace she gets a lot of
times on her hands
oh again they need to stop it says vince
is my favorite character right now the
rest are up to too much
literally that's so true that's
hilarious
um that's amazing i don't know yeah
vince is like he'd just be chilling yeah
y'all need to
i need to get on your way because y'all
are doing too much that's insane
thank you person on twitter
i'm team jeanette no matter what i'm not
afraid to admit i've already
picked a side that is really great for
you i'm actually team vincent
but thank you
thank you so much team vincent is
somewhere in the middle i think everyone
should be teamed up
he's the only one who hasn't made me
want to scream hashtag
oh my god this is the best thing ever
um
never say that ever again the minute i
hear a character speak spanish
well in a show i get a crush so yes
hello [ __ ] tears from cruel summer
italy
it is
yeah for letting me put in a little
spanish here and there
hey olivia holt i'm currently watching
episode 4 of cool summer and it's
amazing he is one of my favorite
characters from the entire series you're
acting in cool summer is the best ever
my mom yes
the end of episode 2 just always gives
me chills every time i see it
oh yeah yeah it's so good i've like just
replayed the end
to watch my girl scream and be like
you can't make that up she's making it
you should make it your ringtone
i am every time someone calls me olivia
being like yeah
oh in all caps it says ben and vince
dancing to massey stars they
got me i'm so happy it's true
it's true oh good so good that's one of
my favorite scenes
yeah i love them so much shout out to
nathaniel
nathaniel my boy
i love working with him so much am i the
only one that thinks jeanette and jamie
had more chemistry than kate and james
idk lol
why did i get the idk oh
feel like annette and jamie are on like
a similar
level of suss maybe they're like the the
new age bonnie and clyde
we're both a little a little crazy i
really don't believe that jeanette saw
they said katie saw katie in that damn
basement
in all caps but i do think she wanted
her life
and she took advantage of her missing to
get her friends
in her mans that's kind of great yeah
yeah story checks out all right
i have a theory that the gunshot
jeannette and jamie heard has something
to do with annabelle
in parentheses whoever whoever
antebellum is close parentheses
um it happened right before kate was
rescued in parentheses again
kate says the other didn't make it out
alive
damn damn yeah
interesting okay yeah
olivia holding cool summer is everything
thanks mom yes
100 okay so we all agree
mallory cannot be trusted once again
that's rude
uh but can we talk about harley quinn
how great she is question mark
i'm fine uh hashtag cruel she's the best
great i'm fine yeah bye bye thank you
check out cool summer on freeform and
[Music]
hulu
you